a work has reportedly restarted on the
controversial nordstrom 2
gas pipeline in the baltic sea almost a
year after u.s sanctions brought the
german-russian project to a standstill
the u.s argues the pipeline is meant to
isolate ukraine and divide the eu
on saturday its ambassador to germany
robin quinnville
repeated calls for germany to end the
billion dollar project
work is underway once again on the
nordstream 2 pipeline
german authorities have given the
go-ahead for the russian ship academic
czersky to lay another 2.6 kilometers of
pipe
by the end of the year but that is
nowhere near enough to complete the
project
a total of 160 kilometers still have to
be laid
only then would the underwater pipeline
be ready allowing russian state-owned
company gazprom to deliver
siberian gas directly to
the germany has been watching
developments with alarm late last week
american lawmakers added measures
against the baltic sea pipeline to the
annual defense budget
these provide for tightened sanctions
against companies that certify or ensure
the pipeline
or that support nordstrom 2 with
products facilities
or services the text in the defense bill
would grant the next u.s president the
right to suspend the sanctions
but that's something few experts on
either side of the atlantic expect
no matter who is in the white house
and for more on this i'm joined now by
maria shagina she's a postdoc fellow at
the center for eastern european studies
at the university of zurich and she
continues to follow nordstrom 2.
maria good morning work supposedly has
already continued again on the pipeline
this weekend
the question now is how far will it get
uh good morning thank you for having me
there is
no yes or uh no question to
to this it's very complicated and
nordstrom 2 is truly a sanctions dilemma
for the biden administration
on the one hand it wants to keep the
pressure on the pipeline to halt it
on the other hand it pledges to revive
the transatlantic relationship that were
poorly damaged under
the previous administration that means
there is a thin line between not
alienating the european
partners but at the same time keeping
the pressure on the pipeline
uh the new sanctions that were issued
last week gives us a
an indication at least as to what policy
shift we can expect from the biden
administration
and ensured more calibrated sanctions on
private companies
at the same time exempting european
governments
and governmental institutions plus
surviving consultations with european
partners at the same time
maria how much more effective will those
sanctions be than what's already been on
the table will they have more teeth
uh the the added sanctions will
definitely make the
completion of the pipeline more
complicated more arduous
so gazprom will face difficulties in
finding an insurance company
in finding a company that would agree to
provide any technology that still
perhaps needs to be
done on academic churcheship and company
that would
test inspect and certify the pipeline
in fact the last one certification will
be the weakest link in the project
to find that company will be uh an rds
task for
for gasprom and even if it finds all of
these companies that would be willing to
be exposed to u.s sanctions and
potentially lose
access to u.s financial market there are
still legal
challenges in the eu to tackle for gas
prom
as we know this may last may this year
gas plural lost its application at
bundesliga germany uh
energy regulator to to be granted
an exemption a derogation from the new
eu rule so
uh the north syrian saga will continue
perhaps uh
for for some time all right maria
shakina with the university of zurich
thank you very much for joining us
thank you